it's a wonder how the people of this
small rural Lancashire Village still
have hope but they do and it's in bucket
loads it's all for Nicola bully still
missing still not at home with her
daughters for them 19 days without a mum
almost every morning Charlotte would say
hi to Nicola they've been neighbors for
five years she says since she
disappeared it's been hell you cannot
have anything but hope and positivity
you have to trust that we're going to
find something
um because
if we haven't got that what what have we
got
um can't just give up and she would
never give up giving up is just not an
option for anyone but during half term
with her kids at home more and more
questions are being asked she's one of
us that's I think why it's hit so many
of us so hard around here the women the
mums because we've all done this walk it
could it feels like it could have been
any one of us the ribbons on the bridge
are a clear indication there's still
hope amongst many and lots of it but on
the ground the police presence is sparse
and from what we've seen the search for
Nicola bully has significantly decreased
over the last week Lancashire police
moved their investigation Downstream
boats and divers in the sea to scan for
any evidence to locate Nicholas
whereabouts they still believe she
accidentally slipped into this huge
tidal River
but today this just one of a handful of
officers searching for Clues police say
they'll continue to look a family keeps
on hoping but almost three weeks on no
one is any closer to finding Nicola in
saman Rasheed Sky News Lancashire